[Música]
escala en París Aída Palau
Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y de France
24 Hoy les hablamos de moda pero no de
una moda cualquiera sino de una moda
sostenible hecha con telas antiguas y
también con cuero vegetal que sale del
cactus lo hacemos con un diseñador
chileno que según la revista Forbes es
uno de los más prometedores de su
generación se trata de guido Vera guido
muchísimas gracias y bienvenido Bueno
usted es natural de punta Arenas en el
sur de chile en la Patagonia y desde muy
pequeño ya tuvo contacto con la costura
me consta que se diseñaba usted mismo
ropa sin embargo no estudia enseguida
diseño pasa primero por estudios de
comunicación y es casi por azar que se
encuentra un verano haciendo un curso en
la escuela San martíns la prestigiosa
escuela San martíns de Londres por donde
han pasado todos los grandes diseñadores
del mundo y fue en ese momento guido que
usted dice Bueno ya está asumo mi
vocación voy a un diseñador Cómo fue lo
que pasa es que cuando me fui a estudiar
a Londres fue porque la verdad que yo
que sabía que quería trabajar en moda la
verdad Pero siempre lo vi desde las
comunicaciones y desde la producción
Entonces cuando llego y me pasa que pude
trabajar en un par de desfiles de la
Fashion week dije como
es esto lo que sí o sí me quiero dedicar
y veía el tema de tener una marca muy
poco lejano pero sí me apoyó mucho el
styling y la producción de moda para
poder llegar al a tener una marca propia
sabes cómo poder dirigirme y poder
inspirarme visualizar que quiero
comunicar a diferencia de lo que ya está
hoy en el mercado unos cursos en Londres
de verano que muy eficaces por la que
veo digamos que fue como una patada de
mi cabeza porque venía de chile tenía 19
años entonces era muy chico todavía
entonces sentía que estaba muy encerrado
en una burbuja como latina muy de allá y
cuando llego a Londres
como explosión explosión y creatividad y
reconocí ser una persona creativa Sabes
porque me eduqué en puntarenas en
colegios súper científicos humanistas en
donde mi vocación era completamente
aplastada no como que guidos creativos
simplemente le daba la matemáticas como
que se quedan siempre en eso sabes
entonces estudiando en Santiago y en San
martíns me di cuenta y dije o sea
apertura bueno vive y trabaja de momento
en Santiago de Chile pero lleva unos
meses por Europa participando en varios
eventos participó en la Fashion week que
masculina de París en junio volverá en
enero y ahora está
preparando la de Milán hablemos de esta
colección que mantiene ese hilo
conductor que le caracteriza líneas
depuradas sostenibilidad así unisex Mira
la colección que estoy presentando
durante el 2022 es el volumen 4 que se
llama micro mundos y que se acompaña
siempre de la colección permanente que
el año pasado post pandemia y esta
colección se llama micro mundos y es la
que presente en marzo acá en París en
abril la presente en Vancouver Fashion
week en una pasarela y esa fue la
colección digamos de invierno Ya ahora
viene en junio para la de hombre y
mostré en la división de verano de esta
colección ya entonces Y esta colección
está inspirada Digamos como en en la
teoría de los micro universos que
existen en el mundo en general sobre
todo pero obviamente mi mi inspiración
siempre está en la Patagonia en
puntarenas en donde hay muchos como
humedales tenemos muchas zonas de esas
de sacrificio o lugares donde las
pastores del painen como centros en
donde la gente de todo el mundo llega a
ver a punta Arenas sabes como que es hay
una isla en particular que trabaja el
tema de los micro mundos como una
pequeña Amazona en la Patagonia entonces
fue un estudio que yo hice de cómo
finalmente
toda una sociedad como converge en los
micro mundos de otras personas sabes
como uno puede llegar a pasar a llevar
la vida de un ser vivo que no conoce por
el simple hecho de estar tomándose un
cigarro sabes como que es una idea que
se mezcla con el camuflaje también de
como nosotros nos camuflamos para
sobrevivir en este en este plano En el
día a día entonces
la paleta de colores está súper
inspirada en las carreteras de la
Patagonia en la Pampa en esa Pampa vacía
en donde solo hay colores neutros tierra
pero resulta que llega el atardecer y
hay una explosión de lilas de amarillos
Naranjos que
siento que no se me puede borrar porque
fueron 17 años en esa carretera y en
ninguno siempre muy presente no es lo
que más conozco como digamos
que mi experiencia con el mundo empezó a
los 20 años cuando me fui a Londres
digamos pero de ahí para atrás
mi único conocimiento era la Patagonia
chilena y Argentina y el sur de chile su
nombre empieza a sonar mucho Bueno su
marca tiene cuatro años y últimamente ya
está sonando mucho vino a París por
primera vez me decía en 2019
incluso he visto a la Irina caramanos la
primera dama de chile aunque creo que no
le gusta mucho que la llamen así
llevando sus túnicas no
da un poco de vértigo que vaya todo tan
rápido Sí la verdad que sí y de hecho
creo que tiene que ver mucho también
porque el fondo yo lo comencé como un
proyecto no sabe O sea si quería que
funcionara obviamente había una algo en
mi corazón que seguido Hazlo hazlo Pero
obviamente uno no sabe si esto puede
fracasar o no entonces
creo que en estos cuatro años he
trabajado con una constancia pero
también como con una
como con una con una identidad que en el
fondo como el tema de la moda vegana
sabes como no animal creo que toda esa
causa ha creado quizás que la marca hoy
en día tenga esta esa vitrina porque me
empecé a mezclar con la innovación con
la tecnología y con un poco de una
sastrería más contemporánea y Sports
la tecnología es importantísima para
hacer
una ropa para diseñar una ropa por la
que usted apuesta no que es vegana que
no utiliza nada nada animal y a mí me ha
sorprendido mucho que podamos hacer
cuero no de un cactus mexicano
explíquenos Cómo es el proceso Cómo se
consigue sacar cuero de un cactus Bueno
la verdad las cosas que
mi objetivo cuando comenzaba a pensar la
marca entre el 2016 17 esto se lanzó el
2018 la marca y comencé trabajando con
un Petro reciclado que te ha comentado
que es un vinil Life que el primer cuero
novio un animal vio degradable que
partió como para tapiz de sillón que son
a partir de botellas de plástico y pero
el proceso tiene un proceso de
biotecnología que hace que se biodegrade
Entonces digamos que es un súper
producto que es de que nace de algo que
la gente hoy en día está Así como hay
plástico no Entonces
siempre dije como Ay cómo no va a
existir un cuero como vegetal como
ustedes no se crea como y un día llamaba
y se miran contra este cuero de cactus
que lo hacen en México como en Facebook
Así como de dos hermanos que se pensaron
esta idea y yo como mamá Gracias Te amo
a ver y empecé a buscar la información y
pedí muestras y vas y es resistente es
súper es bueno es digamos que una
alternativa del cuero obviamente no no
es cuero pero
sabes que mira yo la verdad que como
llevo ya dos años y medio trabajando con
la tela y
el envejecimiento es nulo como que y es
muy impactante como tú también dices que
venga de un vegetal o sea que venga de
un nopal básicamente que no lleva agua
por ejemplo el nopal se riega con el
agua de lluvias en México esto se hace
en Zacatecas específicamente y lo que se
hace Es que no se mata tampoco Al cactus
completo se trabaja con las hojas que
están más maduras por ahí entonces
eventualmente nunca se corta el cactus
completo y eso se hace una masita una
pasta que se paga bajo la tierra y
eventualmente hace una plancha que se
tiñe y eventualmente se mezcla con
policotón algodón o poliéster reciclado
que en el fondo hacen que la la que la
materialidad sea light sabes como que se
mueva Que no quede tosca y que tenga
respiración también porque en el fondo
La idea es poder usarlo y no estar
sudando debajo Claro en su filosofía
también hay una constante aparte de que
sea sostenible esa moda que es que es
una moda unisexy Mi pregunta es Con qué
patrones trabaja con patrones de hombre
o con patrones de mujer porque el cuerpo
de una mujer no es el mismo que el
cuerpo de un hombre no yo por ejemplo lo
que trabajo es el tema lo que me gusta a
mí de la moda unisex es el poder
trabajar a base del cuerpo como que me
pasa que hay hombres que tiene por
ejemplo tienen
te la sabes como que o pueden tener
cáncer de mama por ejemplo porque los
cuerpos son todos creemos que son muy
distintos pero en teoría no somos tan
diferentes como que hay cosas que en el
fondo por ejemplo pueden interferir de
repente en una silueta como tú dices
masculina femenina pero me pasaba mucho
que como esto experimento de la marca
Comenzó desde el algo muy personal de
que yo cuando era niño me ponía de
repente las chaquetas de mi mamá o los
Blazer de trabajo de mi papá para tener
esta figura más oversize Y sabes que
todo esa esa mezcla de cosas me llevaron
a que empezar a mezclar y a jugar y a
romper la ropa y a ver los patrones y a
ver qué ampliar o qué silueta trabajar
es más en común con los cuerpos Entonces
por ejemplo me pasó que yo mucho provee
un pantalón de tiro alto de mujer en
varios hombres a ver hasta donde les
llegaba si les incomodaba Digamos como
en la zona
íntimas y me empezó a fijar que
realmente las diferencias No eran muchas
y que eventualmente el pantalón de tiro
alto
favorece mucho la figura del hombre
entonces bueno
y el pantalón abajo que hace te destruye
la figura o sea es el lowrise de la
Britney del 2000 la destruyó el cuerpo a
la mitad de las mujeres del mundo
Entonces yo tengo esa imagen de los
hombres vestidos con los tirantes no y
los pantalones muy altos y más fino
también como que esta imagen pulcra de
mi moda unisex Sport es esa también como
poder depurar un poco el look clásico
llevarlo algo más Sport a lo del día a
día Pero con materiales digamos que no
son convencionales para la industria
no O sea
depende Sabes porque igual por ejemplo
Hay cosas y cosas de repente que son un
poco pegadas o que muestro como
transparencia pero siempre con una
como con esta idea de dejar para la
imaginación
Bueno le quería preguntar qué país es o
qué continentes son más fans de sus
diseños donde vende más Mira por el
momento ha sido Europa y en este
particularmente en Francia que es donde
más he tenido como ventas o clientes que
en el fondo desde el 2019 la fecha he
podido como mantener pero también y
también gente que no conozco que de
repente llega a la venta y va se llevan
cosas pero
México también fue un lugar en donde se
Vendió bastante la marca Cuando comenzó
y también tiene un público súper
internacional en México y de mucha gente
de afueras mucho francés también y que
muchos de ellos interesaron En la marca
era como hoy Porque no te baja Francia
como Entonces digamos que todas esas
mezclas de cosas porque yo hice una
feria comercial en México antes después
de Francia que es caravana americana que
es súper famosa en marzo previo a la
pandemia entonces descubramos que tuve
ese evento y luego me tuve que en
últimos años entonces ahora me comentaba
que nasia también
qué es lo que yo quería también porque
como es un mercado más amplio y es
gigante y el rubro yanderless o unisex
digamos es está como está ahí alerta
como de estos como de nuevos rostros en
la moda sabes como que creo que
llegué en el momento como quizás preciso
es el futuro tal vez ya el presente No
guido Muchísimas gracias No nos queda
más tiempo le deseamos mucho éxito en
Milán y también en París Gracias y
muchas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir también por internet en rf
y mundo.com y en france24.com Hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]